though Halloween is renowned among
horror hounds the film is not without
its flaws oddities and strange leaps of
logic
none of these examples can diminish the
film's overall legacy but let's not
pretend there aren't some dumb things
everyone ignores about John Carpenter's
Halloween major horror films of the
1970s like Carrie and Last House on the
Left tended to cast 20-somethings in the
roles of teens in this respect Halloween
is no difference that that doesn't make
the casting any less distracting with
the exception of Jamie Lee Curtis who
was 19 at the time Halloween was
released the actors who played the
teenagers were all well into their 20s
PJ Souls the actress who plays Laurie
she lead a friend Linda was 28 years old
similarly Laurie's other friend Annie
was portrayed by 29 year old Nancy Kai's
when all three girls are together on
screen is incredibly awkward to watch
two grown women pretend to be high
school girls when paired with Curtis who
is noticeably younger than the other two
actresses the glaring age differences
are impossible to ignore
I forgot my chemistry book after Michael
breaks out of Smith's Grove sanitarium
at the beginning of the film dr. Loomis
rightfully fears what Michael will do
with his newfound freedom he takes his
concern to the police but it's probably
brushed off leaving him to hunt Michael
on his own because your patient doctor
precautions weren't strong enough you
should have told somebody everybody
suspecting Michael or returned his
childhood home
Loomis makes his way to Haddonfield on
his way he stops at a payphone and by
pure circumstance stumbles onto an
abandoned car while the camera pans to
show the audience that drivers body
lying nearby Loomis is not privy to the
murder nevertheless the good doctor
somehow surmises at the abandoned car in
a stream of a solid proof that Michael
Myers was there what's so bizarre about
this scene isn't just the unlikely
circumstances or Loomis's apparent sixth
sense but the fact that he doesn't
appear to report the crime at all if
Loomis is genuinely concerned about what
he found why wouldn't he call the police
if he had taken even a minute to look
around and not run off after finding a
random matchbook on the ground he would
have seen the dead body and it would
have likely forced the police to
cooperate while we don't know much about
the specific events are triggered
Loomis's a
men's fear of Michael it's safe to say
that doctor knows far more about the
killer's violent tendencies than anyone
else after breaking out of confinement
stealing a car assaulting a woman and
killing an innocent man you think anyone
hunting Michael would at least be
cautious surprisingly the hunt for
Michael is incredibly low-key Loomis
seeks out the help of Haddonfield
sheriff Leigh Brackett and the to hunt
Michael alone at some points the sheriff
suggests a full-blown manhunt but Loomis
tosses the idea aside for fear of
causing a panic if you do that they'll
see him on every street corner they look
for him in every house just tell your
men to keep their mouths shut and
horizon meanwhile Michael is walking
around killing teenagers and terrorizing
Laurie
it seems hypocritical from Loomis of all
people to prefer discretion over action
at the beginning of the film he was
desperately seeking police help but when
he finally gets it he turns he offer
down if a full search was organized
maybe Laurie's friends wouldn't have
been butchered when Annie and Laurie
stumble onto a recently robbed hardware
store and his father tells him that
someone has stolen a Halloween mask some
knives and rope
the robbery must have just happened as
the alarm is blaring in the background
and a group of police officers are
actively surveying the scene given the
context the film is hinting that Michael
is the one who stole the mask and the
murder tools in theory that makes sense
but given the fact that the girls had
already encountered a mass Michael far
before the robbery supposedly occurred
he couldn't have stolen the mask the
first time we see Michael after he
escapes from Smith's Grove is when he
waits outside of Laurie's school clearly
already wearing the mask hours later
when Laurie walks home with her friends
the group encounters Michael twice a
white before Laurie goes out with Annie
she spots him again outside of her
window all of these occurrences happen
before Michael supposedly Bob's the
store and yet in all of them he's
wearing the mask unless he robbed
another store and took another identical
mask for good measure this timeline just
doesn't add up there was understandable
that Laurie would make some mistakes in
a life-or-death situation it's less
acceptable that she would make the same
mistake three times when Michael
surprises Laurie from inside the Doyle
house she reflexively stabs the killer
with a knitting needle
Michael falls to the
seemingly defeated in typical horror
fashion however he is very much alive
and pursues Laurie again shortly after
again Laurie attacks Michael jabbing him
in the eye with a coat hanger and
stabbing him with a knife
Michael is down once more but instead of
checking to see if he's done for good
Laurie makes the same mistake as before
and just assumes he's dead not ready to
call it quits Michael gets right back up
this time illumise takes the offensive
and shoots him causing Michael to fall
up at the balcony
despite Laurie failing to kill Michael
twice before she illumise decide it's
better to have a conversation rather
than check to make sure the fall or the
gunshots successfully killed Michael
matter of fact it was by the time anyone
bothers to look he's long gone
if Loomis or Laurie had cared enough to
check Michaels pulse they wouldn't have
to worry about him continuing his
killing spree
then again how else would he have had so
many Halloween sequels being a
low-budget independent film created in a
short period Halloween naturally
couldn't avoid its fair share of little
mistakes ranging from continuity errors
to production goofs but eagle-eyed
viewers may be able to catch for example
a crew member is reflected in the phone
booth glass right before Loomis
discovers the driver Michael killed on
his way to hurt him field though it can
be a bit hard to notice you can see
Linder stumble as she and Bob head
upstairs in the Wallace house apparently
PJ Souls didn't just lose her footing
the actress tripped over a dolly truck
and when Annie is teasing Laurie about
Michael in front of the hedges a puff of
smoke is briefly caught on camera a
calling to John Carpenter the smoke came
from his own cigarette check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more loop of videos but your favorite
horror movies are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bowel
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]